I'm 20 you know one years old how do you
get unstuck how do you do this I said
okay well here's where you let's start
here your whole life is about those
little things that you do every day and
if you're not happy get out a piece of
paper draw a line down the center and
write down the things that you were
doing when you were happier or healthier
person
and add one in tomorrow
and if you simply just get out for that
walk or buy yourself those flowers or
start texting a friend today to make
plans put your name on the list for one
of the Huts for the national park in the
spring so you have something to look
forward to
your life contains the clues to what
actually makes you feel a little happier
and when they're sitting there on a
piece of paper and then you take a piece
of duct tape and you tape that sucker to
the wall next to your bed so that when
you wake up in the morning you see that
there's the roadmap pick one of those
damn things
you'll slowly start to feel better and
if you can feel better today you can
feel better tomorrow